Central Bank digital currency so this is  basically a psycho cryptocurrency but  it's not because they'll be entirely  centralized which means they can  completely control the money they can  program it so if for whatever reason you  hold the wrong opinion you say the wrong  thing on social media you become an  Andrew Tate whatever it is it's much  easier to shun you from society because  they can control your money that's why  I'm forever bullish on bitcoin because  the money is non-confiscatable so if you  don't get your vaccine it doesn't matter  we won't confiscate your money like  Justin Trudeau did bitcoin's  non-confiscatable limited Supply  decentralized